let's talk a little bit about
uh uh heart attacks and i got five
topics with you that i want to go
through one of them is
what's your an expertise expert in which
is doing cardiac and heart surgeries
in the world of business you're in
pressure a lot
a lot you're having to make ends meet
when you're starting the business you
have to hit
numbers you hire people you fire people
you're hated sometimes you got
competitors you got
defamation of character you got rumors
you got challenges you got
running out of money you got economy you
got market you got all this stuff that's
going on
and you have to take care of your family
your wife your husband your kids
all the stuff you're dealing with
obviously there's a lot of pressure
right a lot of pressure that builds up
and many times you know i'm in a lot of
different circles amongst other
entrepreneurs that are running
good-sized businesses
what's starting to happen a lot that's
coming up to me and i kind of want to
run this by you and see
what your take will be on this is
a lot a lot of people are experiencing
panic attacks and anxiety attacks and
they're
wondering if it's a heart attack
okay and so you have a very similar
symptom here your chest feels heavy
your palms get sweaty you feel a lot of
pressure like an elephant that's
stepping on your chest
and then you realize it's a panic attack
you go to the hospital say no you're not
having a heart attack you're totally
fine
it's a panic attack what is the
difference symptom between having a
heart attack and a panic attack
interestingly enough not much and
so many times
particularly in the emergency room when
someone like this comes in
luckily there are blood tests that are
available to tell the difference right
away
within you know 30 minutes that it's a
panic attack versus
a heart attack or there are no ekg
changes for instance on a heart tracing
but there's particularly i think
you're right there is a
high level of
anxiety um particularly obviously for
the last six months
with covet 19 and we're seeing
a lot of people presenting with anxiety
interestingly enough as an aside most
people think that when they're under a
lot of stress
their cortisol levels are high and
that's why things are going so wrong
conversely as i talk about in my
upcoming book the energy paradox a lot
of people
think the same thing is adrenal fatigue
that they burned out their adrenals
because of the stress
and i can assure you and your listeners
and viewers
that about 95 of people who
think they have anxiety or high cortisol
or conversely adrenal fatigue have
absolutely normal cortisol levels
absolutely normal and it's
cortisol and adrenal fatigue is
unfortunately
it's one of those wonderful internet
myths and it sells books
um but it's it's very very rare
so similar symptoms similar feel
everything's the same
so so when i when i when i hear people
telling me because i watch my dad go
through a lot of heart attacks
himself so he would say you feel pain
here
your jaw almost tightens up a little bit
right
and the pressure is a little bit
center a little bit left i don't know if
that's correct your left arm
tightens up a little bit of your left
leg any other symptoms that you notice
from all the
patients you've dealt with all these
years well interesting women
have very very different symptoms uh you
know
you're you're describing typical male
symptoms uh certainly the elephant
sitting on your chest is another good
example
women unfortunately often
have none of these and women more often
will
talk about having a queasy feeling in
their stomach
or having a sense of nausea
or belching or burping and
that frequently is they'll just go oh
that's indigestion and what the heck
you know i'll i'll ignore it i'll take a
you know a couple of tums and i'll ride
this out
and interestingly when you start
actually talking with men the number of
men
through the years that have angina
or narrowings in their coronary arteries
oftentimes they will attribute this to
heartburn and uh
i'll tell you a funny story back in the
early days
uh before modern tests we used to joke
as hart and esophagus surgeons that
half the time people we did bypasses on
what they
actually had was heartburn and half the
time
people who we would operate on their
esophagus for reflux
they actually had coronary artery
disease we just didn't have
the ability to tell the difference um
and i think
so a lot of particularly you know the
the lay public
number one men in particular
are great deniers um of
ah you know it's a it's a toothache or
uh ah you know i have too many spicy
meatballs tonight and i'll just go to
bed
um women because i think of their role
as the matriarch of the family
don't want to bother anybody and quite
frankly
physicians to this day every
study that's ever been done show that
physicians
do not give as much credibility to a
woman's complaint
as to a man's complaint and
much of women's heart disease is missed
or ignored
until often it's too late
so why is that
um you know don't get me started but
for the last curious well for the last
20 years
um in my new role in in restorative
medicine teaching people how to reverse
diseases rather than operating on them
i've come to realize that
women just as a general rule get
real short shrift from health care
providers
their complaints are and i was taught
this their complaints are not to be
believed
they're they're hysterical they're
emotional
um this is all in their head
and one of the things that i guess has
made me
famous is that i've come to learn
from my patients many of whom are women
with autoimmune diseases
that believe it or not it is not in
women's head
and if if a woman has a complaint
it's it's to be taken seriously now
i'm you know i'm a father of two
daughters and i'm married
to a woman and i have three female dogs
so
maybe i'm biased from that but i think
one of the things
we as a profession
we really have not given women their due
in
listening to their complaints
that's uh that that's i just pulled up a
stat while you were saying this to just
kind of look at the numbers
this is from caring seniorservice.com
uh men experience heart attacks more
than women
between 789 of sudden heart attacks are
experienced by
men not women why why do you think
men have more heart attacks than women
do
well it's number one men
tend to ignore
what they should be paying attention to
um
if if if i had
you can't believe the number of men who
for instance
are out on a golf course and
have an issue i mean they've got an
elephant sitting on their chest
and they go ah you know it's just hot
out here and i'll go have a beer
and the elephant's still sitting on
their chest ah you know it was just a
little heat stroke
and i'll go home and then the next thing
you know at two o'clock in the morning
uh somebody's pounding on their chest
and you know i'm whipping him into the
operating room they've had a massive
heart attack
and they just
men are really good at denial um
we're we're really good at it i would
agree with that 100
yeah i would totally agree with that you
you think
you think half of it is just our
pride and ego of being untouchable i
have to play this role of this tough guy
that i don't have to go see the doctor i
don't need it it's not a big deal i'm
okay i'm gonna be fun do you think it's
more that macho thing that we have to be
this tough guy
i think it's part of that i think the
other part is
uh this it it can't happen to me i you
know i'm in
such good shape uh that's nonsense
that's not what i'm having
[Music]
you